una clase de actuación para preparar una
escena de sexo Claire borden enseña este
grupo de actrices Cuáles deben ser sus
límites
la mayoría de actores tienen una
historia en la que su consentimiento no
ha sido respetado o han tenido una
experiencia dolorosa en el set
especialmente en escenas con desnudos y
sexo y esto pasa con todos los actores y
géneros también durante la clase hay un
momento para aprender a ponerse una
tanga especial habitual en las escenas
sexuales
realmente lo que hacemos Es apoyar la
narración y garantizar que los actores
mantengan la autonomía de sus cuerpos
para que puedan dar su consentimiento a
lo que están haciendo y cuando los
actores se sienten escuchados atendidos
y apoyados consiguen hacer mejor su
trabajo
el movimiento mito ha traído consigo una
nueva industria el de las coordinadoras
de intimidad las actrices lo celebran
la semana pasada estuve filmando escenas
de sexo luego me enteré de este tipo de
trabajo y dije este es el lenguaje y la
comunicación que se necesitan para este
tipo de escenas en los últimos cinco
años el movimiento mitú ha descubierto
las miserias de la industria
cinematográfica poniendo la lupa en
directores de la talla de Román Polanski
señalados de acoso sexual o el más
paradigmático el productor Harvey
weinstein cuyo juicio por crímenes
sexuales empieza este lunes en Los
Ángeles tras ya haber sido condenado a
23 años de prisión en Nueva York después
de ser acusado por más de 90 mujeres